with incurable illness or advanced age
life can easily become agony so some
people would prefer to die than waste
away active euthanasia is illegal in
Germany but assisted suicide is allowed
for instance by giving someone a fatal
medicine cocktail even for a fee but
doctors risk their jobs if they help a
patient die most Germans think that rule
is wrong ones i understand it should be
allowed yes and i think doctors should
do it who else varun zones i think that
depends on the individuals disease
that's to have doctors have sworn to
save lives and this presents them with a
serious conflict in the ethical conflict
mainlanders if you leave it up to the
free market that won't do justice to its
ethical and moral significance but oi
dong finish greatest should doctors be
allowed to help people commit suicide
ten percent say yes definitely
sixty-nine percent think doctors should
only be allowed to help the incurably
ill to die and eighteen percent say
doctors should never assist suicide the
governing coalition wants to toughen the
laws the bundestag may put an end to
assisted suicide in exchange for pay
you